il est probablement le résident le plus
marquant de l'histoire d'Annecy le
souvenir de Maurice Richard légende du
hockey et d'ailleurs encore bien vivant
dans le quartier et depuis 5 ans c'est
même la circonscription qui porte son
nom c'est Audrey
en 2018 à cette fois bon espoir de
l'emporter et mis sur l'avocate Audrey
c'est très favorable je pense que les
gens reconnaissent aussi mon profil les
gens sont studieux ont regardé ce que
j'avais fait dans la vie auparavant
alors je pense que le vent est du bon
côté pour nous cette fois-ci
c'est moi qui me présente ici pour être
votre prochain député avec Québec
solidaire Aaron Boisy un travailleur du
monde de la finance représente les
solidaires qui avaient perdu par à peine
500 voix la dernière fois on a dépassé
le demi-milier de bénévoles juste ici
dans Maurice Richard donc on est très
confiant nos solutions répondent aux
problèmes de la population en matière
d'éducation d'accès à la santé de
logement bonjour je m'appelle Jonathan
Marleau je suis le candidat pour Maurice
Richard le candidat libéral directeur
dans une banque tente aussi de succéder
à Marie mon petit qui avait été élu sous
la bannière de son parti elle avait
ensuite été expulsée du caucus en raison
d'allégation de harcèlement
psychologique les gens sont
reconnaissants de son passage en
politique maintenant c'est sûr que moi
je peux juste me tourner vers l'avenir
aussi donc quand on va présenter aux
gens c'est surtout l'éducation sont
surtout orientés sur qu'est-ce qui se
passe après le 3 octobre
j'ai plus mon idée mais on peut entendre
le convaincre s'il reste encore des
indécis je parle comme ça et je pense
que c'est leader vous hésitez entre
quelle partie le libéral puis le CAC la
plupart des électeurs rencontrés avaient
déjà fait leur choix la partie québécois
pourquoi
je pense que c'est un homme qui sait où
ce qui s'en va
je trouve que ça représente pas mal
notre génération des jeunes le Parti
vert j'ai confiance en Lui
moi je suis depuis que c'est comment
parce que j'ai entendu dire que c'est
les gens c'est eux qui s'intéressaient
le plus à l'environnement
va faire une grande différence c'est une
vraie course alors on est sur le terrain
à tous les jours Jacques parti profite
maintenant du dernier sprint pour faire
le plein d'appui mais tout se voit déjà
sur la plus haute marche du podium votre
niveau de confiance de 0 à 10 en vue de
lundi
je dirais 9,5 oui un bon 9,5 quand même
il faut se garder une gêne dans une
circonscription qui a l'habitude des
changements de couleur la rondelle et
maintenant dans le camp des électeurs
si Mathieu papillon Radio-Canada
Montréal